you have some tattoos I do I have some  tattoos Salemi ones and you have one  that I hadn't seen before I think we  have a picture of it some people think  that this is two bunnies going at it  yeah  bunnies fornicating see this cuz I I  didn't get it because it looks like  bunnies fornicating no what did you see  Andy it looks like a rabbit it looks  like a rat yes one rabbit who else  thinks it looks like bunnies yeah clap  if you think it looks like bunnies  it looks like doggystyle from behind you  got a twofer one with exact yeah it  tells you a lot about the person these  are perverse people but it tells you a  lot about the person what they see  that's true yeah any time I meet someone  I'll be like what do you see yeah  exactly yeah tell me what you